oh why is going on YouTube you like this
hair looks like I have children and a
family so if you guys remember last week
I did a skit called Kingdom era number
one husband North Korea who aged and my
kingdom era so for those of you out
there aren't really acquainted with Kim
Jong Villa kids amulet is the only
character that I've ever done and the
last time that I did at Kim Jong Billis
kid was about two years ago now the skit
that I wrote I wrote it about a year and
a half ago or so now with that in mind
the main reason why I didn't do this gig
was obviously I got really busy with
with you know with all the stuff that I
was doing it on top of that Kim Jong Il
passed away but you know I said [ __ ] it
I'm bringing back anyway
he's one of my favorite characters that
I've ever done and obviously the only
ones Oakley out there goes but if you
guys are wondering about this accent
he's actually was actually developed
from my uncle accident this kid that I
met in college named Andy Jiang and this
[ __ ] has a weirdest lucky create
an accent I just kind of took that and
melted it into one melted did it I did
it and of course in the skin was the
very lovely and beautiful talented hard
and Cho and for those of you out there
who are not acquainted with Iron Chef
which probably you guys are she is from
Teen Wolf
also known as Keira or also as my friend
that you seen her in a previous kiss
before and we've done a lot of stuff
together some but art and thank you my
dear for coming out and killing this
role because this kid we're not having a
saying if you did not do it so thank you
very much and I love you very much girl
mm-hmm and by the way in the comments a
lot of you guys are saying stuff like I
[ __ ] you too what what does that mean as
far as I'm concerned I ship you is like
a racist term ton you gonna ship us back
to Asia or some [ __ ]
is that true and that's true the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you I'm not going back there I like
to hear it's nice it's cozy
the weather's nice and of course we had
another cameo in there if you guys don't
know who he is we have done music
together before his name is Z was one of
the dopest R&B artists out there on the
YouTube space or just in general it was
a bodyguard that I slap the [ __ ] out of
but once again this kid came back
because a lot of you guys were I should
suggest
that I do it again and will there be
more ourselves I don't know it really
depends if you guys want more and you
know what I just might because I do like
a character but anyways you guys who
asked me for the BTS and you guys want
to know what this was about
and so yes Kim jong-il is a rapper from
North Korea originally and basically you
know he came to America to start a new
life in the American ways and he's
finding out is really hard to be
whatever he wants because you know she's
tough out here in a cave I'm saying and
specifically for this one the
relationship that they had was actually
based on my aunt and uncle it's a very
loving type of relationship but it's
extremely violent but anyways my people
enjoy the BTS let me know what you think
and if you guys don't like it
go [ __ ] yourself table get out of the
way one dinner yeah
hey what's that one oh there it comes to
be honest I'm not happy
sorry I like to leave - did you with the
chopsticks there ah get school Cold
Stunner would you like vacation yeah no
I'll pull this up get the are you get
here she can up Oh II the bottom yeah
the tops your cheek is a ghetto channel
all that you buy Guevara ego ego much
yeah or take one that's Kim Jung eater
lover he's wide oh hello what is going
on you two anything comes out no but yes
if you guys are wondering Oh what did
you get that lovely lovely shirt yes go
for broke has just launched a part of
their spring apparel which is the first
design which is Topher the Gopher in
camo top of the Gopher is our new mascot
for go for broke and of course we have a
camo hat to match this right here with
3d embroidery in the front a camo bill
and of course a black leather strap bag
yes custom hats are in a lot of you guys
out there have been complaining that you
guys have not been able to get your gear
and once again it's because these things
are made in limited quantities so if you
can't get it you can't get it you know I
really apologize but you gotta hop on it
and of course wore our faux fur program
you guys already know that when we put
out a couple new designs on the spring
light that they are out a discounted
price so you can actually get the
leather strap back and the shirt at a
discounted price for a limited time so
caught that gear before it runs out and
don't complain what it does because I
just told y'all it was limited so famil
see you guys soon and you know I'll be
always posting these videos on that
Sunday and Wednesday so remember I will
see y'all soon and uh come here give me
a kiss right here that's scary right